I told you last week that Donald Trump
hit 60 percent disapproval that was a
presidency high for him disapproval
rating we have a new Associated Press n
o RC Center for public affairs Research
poll - mouthful which finds that 61% of
Americans believe that Donald Trump
committed the felony of obstruction of
justice by trying to impede the Russia
investigation but none of this is true
pat the failing mainstream media fake
news clowns are making it all up
give Trump a break he's new at this he
didn't know you're not supposed to
commit felonies and then go online and
tell Lester Holt that you did it
simultaneous to this yet another one of
these very damaging polls for Donald
Trump Donald Trump is claiming that his
approval rating is higher than Barack
Obama's what on earth is Trump talking
about let's try to unwind it Donald
Trump tweeted over the weekend quote the
new Rasmussen poll one of the most
accurate in the 2016 election just out
with a trump 50 percent approval rating
that's higher than Obama's numbers last
week the President had tweeted an image
of a Rasmussen Reports poll which puts
his approval at 50% the first time it is
above 50% or at 50% since April now
there are two issues here Pat as I'm
sure you would have guessed there's not
just one problem
now with what Donald Trump is saying one
issue is do you trust Rasmussen / Gallup
which has been doing presidential
approval tracking for decades and has
Trump in the mid to high 30s but it
doesn't matter whether you trust
Rasmussen / Gallup because even looking
at data from Rasmussen from January of
2009 at that point
Rasmussen had Obama at 67 percent
approval compared with Donald Trump's 59
percent of the time in June of 2009
these sort of equivalent point to right
now for Obama President Obama had a 55
percent approval rating according to
Rasmussen Reports
compared to Donald Trump's 50% right now
this is a common theme for Trump in fact
I would sort of call it the overarching
theme for his first five months in
office Trump says something goes on
Twitter Trump says something
demonstrably false it is demonstrated to
be false
independent and some corporate media
point out that it's false and then they
are called out as fake news for having
pointed out Trump made something up by
Donald Trump and Trump supporters this
is the theme of the presidency and to
add another layer here Rasmussen the day
before the election had Hillary up two
points right which is correct that's how
much she won by yep but I thought
according to Donald Trump that he would
have won the popular vote by three to
five million people had not so many
people voted illegally so it turns out
that even Rasmussen is not that
trustworthy by Donald Trump's own logic
people still by the way talk when they
say not that there's approval polls are
done differently than pre-election polls
pre-election polls are done based on on
what's called a likely voter model we
don't have to dig into it but in any
case there's no similarity at all
between approval rankings and
pre-election polling but so many Trump
is say you trust polls after how wrong
they were about the 2016 election the
polls were right Hillary was up by two
to three and she won the popular vote by
two to three that's what national polls
look at yeah all the polls that I saw
had Hillary winning by one to six and of
course there's a margin of error there
but but Trump has been honest in the
fact that sometimes he believes the
polls and sometimes he doesn't believe
holes depends on whether or not they
favor him it's the same thing as if you
like Trump and say good things about him
you're the best person in the world
you're just such a great person same
person says something negative can't be
trusted
failing Low Energy sad not credible and
think about the chain of claims from
Trump now I've got a higher approval
rating than Obama at this time false
three to five million people voted
illegally for Hillary Clinton false I'm
the healthiest president ever my doctors
say said so shameful claim for a doctor
to make I'm like a smart person you be
the judge of that one I don't want to
dig into that one it's the theme this is
the theme of the
Trump presidency and these comparisons
to Obama over and over again demonstrate
some sort of bizarre complex because I
think he realizes he'll never be as
popular or historic as a president as
Barack Obama would include he'll try to
undermine his legacy but that's all he
really can do and try to undo every bit
of it that he can we'll get to that a
little bit later on in the show